[Music]
first up labor conference was a chance
for kiyosama to show people what kind of
prime minister he wants to be but most
of the headlines were about a shadow
cabinet resignation and fighting over
rule changes was it all bad though i'm
joined now by the spectator's deputy
political editor katie balls katie
thanks for joining me you were at labour
party conference this week now the big
news for most people across the country
was the fuel crisis with all the
attention on that one might think that
labor would take the opportunity to
really get at the tories
yes it didn't quite happen like that no
um it was interesting covering labour
conference now clearly uh both kirsten
and his team spend weeks perhaps even
months in advance planning the substance
of their speeches working out what they
want their main themes to be but the
fact this was also happening at a time
when most people in the country were
waking up and not sure they could get to
work how the fuel crisis is going to
affect them meant lots of the uh you
know people present at the conference
both labour mps and even international
visitors were slightly bemused it didn't
play a more central role it was
mentioned in the leaders speech but
that's the very end of conference and i
think that for example i had one
diplomat say to me not you know
particularly loaded they just simply
asked you know why didn't kiss dharma
begin conference uh filling up cars
perpetual trying to um at brighton at a
petrol station and it would have gotten
lots of press now i think that you could
clearly say something like that would be
a stunt but it would get you a certain
level of exposure and i think show that
labour was part of a conversation which
uh you know it's the con is the
conversation the country is currently in
and instead it just very much felt like
the labour party spent most of
conference talking to itself now i think
that in some ways i think that's needed
to get the party into the right place to
then talk to the country but it
therefore served as a reminder of how
much work labor has to do to get to the
point where it is election fit
so if labor wasn't focusing on the fuel
crisis from most of conference what were
they focused on
there are a range of things i think if
you look at the initial headlines from
labour conference it wasn't particularly
what
team starman would have desired
we had a row on the first day after
angela rainer the deputy leader uh used
a speech or a reception so this was
later in the evening we can say um to
talk about tory scum and so then there
was a rau kistama's big andrew marr
interview which is supposed to be the
scene setter had to spend a fair bit of
time with uh andrew marsk and kierstarma
if it's appropriate to call tory's gum
he didn't but he didn't you know say
that he'd asked angela rainer to
apologize um and then we also had uh
various trans issues coming up um i
think in that same interview you had
kids down and say that it was wrong to
say only women have a cervix and
therefore cervix was trending on twitter
quite a lot actually of the whole
conference period of lots of events
bringing that back to the fall and then
i think uh we can say the thrust in the
sense of what was in stamina's control
and he chose to do anyway were the rule
changes and so you had days of you know
battles internal faction or warfare over
rule changes and particularly on
how
many people need to support a labour
leader
for for kirsten successor taking power
away from the membership and
kirsten did win to a degree on this he
didn't get everything he wanted through
but he got a version of it and but and
therefore his team are very optimistic
about that they think it's going to mean
that they can be more bullish in the
future because labour mps are harder to
deselect it's harder to challenge
kirsten from the left but the flip side
of that is
we all got to see labour's dirty laundry
played out um and the fact that there is
still plenty of division
so in your piece for the magazine this
week you talk about the infighting that
defined labour party conference but in
terms of those fights who came out on
top is kiyostama stronger weaker coming
out of conference
i think stamina is stronger i think the
issue is stronger and stronger two
different things right and we have a
situation where it's
fairly low expectations kirsten did
manage to get the upper hand on the left
of his party i think by the end of it
even those heckles during kirsten's
speech
very varied the heckling we had you know
where's peter mandelson i think someone
at one point shouted about julian
assange um but also a big focus on the
minimum wage the fact that um
one of the dramas of labour conference
was uh that uh kirsten had a member of
shadow cabinet quit because he won't
agree to the idea of raising the minimum
wage to 15 pounds so there's a lot of
that and but i think the fact that
kirsten got through that speech and it
wasn't put off and showed that he was
standing up to that side of his party
and in a way played to his benefit
but again we do go back to the point
that he has managed to show that he is
in control of various parts of his party
but there's still that side who out
against him and we're not yet sure what
he plans to do with that
so labor actually struggled to make a
lot of the front pages throughout their
conference and now we're going into tory
party conference from this sunday how
are labor going to continue to make
themselves relevant over the next few
weeks and make those headlines how do
they go about attacking the government
during their conference
well going back to the fuel crisis you'd
think there's plenty of things labour
could do in the coming days and weeks um
i think it is inevitably the case that
when it is a party's conference they
tend to dominate the news you for
example in the past we haven't seen many
ministers going onto the airwaves
because there's a bit of a code of
conduct there we get the other take um
center stage so i think tory conference
is clearly being dominated by the tories
and kirsten's best hope is that the
tories mess up in some way they say the
wrong thing or you know the crisis
around them gets worse and that will
dominate it but longer term i think
kirsten needs to work out how he can get
in on the national conversation and
that's something which um
he didn't prove at this conference yes
he made some progress but he didn't
appear reactive
able to respond to changing events in
the way that i think many in his party
would like him to be
katie thanks for joining me and i'm now
joined by the journalist and former
labor advisor aisha hazurika and the
columnist and trade unionist paul embry
hi to both of you thanks for joining
spectator tv
are you sure you wrote in your column
for the evening standard that stama had
a good week what do you mean by that
so i think it didn't start off as a good
week but i think it that that pain was
necessary to get to the end point which
was quite a good week
the most important thing that he did is
that a year ago he said that the parties
under new management this year he proved
it
and that's because he has taken on the
hard left in the party
through those rule changes the most
important rule changes are the mps now
don't have to look over their shoulder
about being de-selected by a noisy group
of marxists in their local labour
constituency parties
and the other important rule change was
that he's hopefully meant that another
jeremy corbyn or hard left candidate
will not ever be leader of the labour
party again so they're really important
things
and i think his big message from the
conference speech yes there was lots of
this is who i am and there was some sort
of policy stuff but i think it was him
sending a message to the country saying
i am not
jeremy corbyn we're not having that kind
of politics anymore and i'm moving the
labour party to the mainstream i think
the heckles were incredibly helpful for
him in fact so good they could have even
been planted it allowed him to use that
pre-scripted line saying oh on a you
know at noon on a wednesday i'm normally
getting heckled by tories and say look
you know you can chant empty slogans or
you can change lives so it allowed him
to kind of deliver those things so i
think that's the big message that's got
out however there's still such a long
way to go by no means as labour
connecting with the public yet but i
think after this conference he's at
least got the party on the pitch
paul do you agree that tama had a good
week and is that the same thing as the
labor party having a good week
i thought he had a reasonable week um he
ended up kind of getting a score draw
out of the proposals for how we elect
the leader on future um he kind of
snatched that score draw really from the
the jaws of defeat in some respects
um i thought his speech was okay
uh i thought in delivery it was a bit
stilted a bit wooden i thought the
content was fairly good i wouldn't
really pitch it higher than that um
he
talks about the
the two rocks of his life being
family and work um i think that was a
good line um
too rarely frankly in recent years as
the labour party talks about the issues
that really matter to ordinary working
people uh and issues like family and
work essential to that he also in his
speech touched on stuff like patriotism
the importance of the armed forces
respect for the armed forces the
importance of law and order and tackling
crime um so in that respect he was
clearly pitching towards some of those
voters
who who labour have lost over recent
years um
but you know the the reality is
whatever whatever kia stammer thinks
about the direction of the labour party
that the labour party needs to go in and
i do think he does or is developing a
clear idea around that
the reality is large parts of the party
simply don't want to go there and when i
say large parts i'm not just talking
about the kind of radical
corbynite left the hard left who clearly
don't like any of that kind of faith
family and flag stuff um but frankly the
liberal left as well um you know the
more centrists the blair right left who
don't really do that stuff instinctively
but probably have the now to realize
that labour has got to speak that
language in order to win over
working-class voters and and the
mainstream um so so yes stammer i think
is developing a clear-eyed idea of where
the party needs to go but whether or not
the party's going to go within um
remains to be seen for me there's still
a mountain to climb and i think the
party's still very much in the foothills
aisha what do you make of that i mean
the corbinises aren't going to disappear
overnight nor does the labour party
necessarily want them to completely
disappear surely they'll want them on on
polling day to show up in and vote labor
is stomach trying to straddle too many
horses at one time
no i i don't think he is i think the
really noisy disruptive
difficult sort of malign elements of the
of the sort of corbin project i think
they are actually quite sort of small in
number and i think that star and his
team have been quite hard and in
cracking down in them so for example one
of the things that i really noticed was
that this year at conference just the
atmosphere was much better i know there
was a little bit of heckling in the hall
but in previous years under jeremy
corbyn it has been a very very
uncomfortable quite aggressive
intimidating atmosphere at labour party
conference i know certainly people come
up to me and lots of finger pointing and
really being super aggressive somebody
spat at me once so there was there was
none of that this time yes it was not
all you know hunky dory on the floor so
i think that the team have already been
very very clear in saying to those
people we don't want you anywhere near
the party so i don't think they feel
that they do need those um corbin people
what i think they do need though and and
this is something that paul has just
sort of touched on you know a lot of
people in the labour party are
progressive that's one of the reasons
they're in the labour party so of course
you know he he's done this first job of
saying look we've done some kind of
hygiene on the party we've got the party
in order but he is going to have these
tensions when it comes to
policy going forward some of that will
be ideological in terms of liberal
values you know butting up against
other things a lot of those are going to
be fiscal as well we saw this big ride
with andy mcdonald over a 15 pound
minimum wage which look many people
would love but what reach reeves who had
a very good conference she had a really
excellent conference she's setting out
you know some very very kind of tough
fiscal new rules for the party she's
saying no i'm not having it that shadow
ministers go out and freelance in terms
of making up policy which is basically
what was happening under jeremy corbyn
so i don't think they're going to shed
any tears about more bus stops with kind
of carbonite or more bus stops
in terms of value for money and fiscal
responsibility but that doesn't mean
it's going to be easy there are going to
be tensions down the track in terms of
where that biting point is in terms of
balancing you know progressive labor
values with with where the the country
and might be and what might be popular
paul you've been critical of the labour
party in the past for focusing too much
on identity politics there was no
shortage of culture wars at labour's
conference this week what did you make
of it
well there hasn't been a shortage of
culture was in the labour party or on
the broader left for
many years now so so it's to be expected
in many ways and unfortunately i think
because of having
immersed itself in uh in identity
politics um the the the party has
if you like widened that chasm between
it and ordinary working-class photos and
you know you saw some of this stuff
during
um during the conference i mean i
switched on one morning i heard uh a
delegate calling for rosie duffield to
to have the whitworth drawn because she
was transphobic i had another delegate
complaining that there you know were
were women-only spaces in terms of the
the toilets in the conference or when
you just kind of think look if ordinary
people are switching onto this which
probably most of them aren't but if they
were
what would they make of this stuff the
labour party in many respects has
positioned itself on the fringe on some
of these issues and has shown that its
priorities or certainly the priorities
of large parts of the party over recent
years are simply not the priorities of
ordinary people across this country and
i i think the key question for labour is
this but how do they win back the red
wall how do they win back those vast
chunks of the country
which were labor since time immemorial
until 2019 but abandoned labor in their
millions provincial britain small town
britain blue collar britain these people
who
as i say would have been tribally labor
once upon a time but felt so abandoned
by the party and felt that the labour
party sneered at them and mocked them
and simply didn't want their votes
anymore and labor needs to try to
to retrieve that historic coalition um
that coalition between what i've called
hampstead and hartley for you know the
more liberal the more metropolitan white
collar voters on the one hand but also
provincial britain working class britain
blue collar britain voters with you know
soft conservative
values and views on on social and
cultural issues um and that coalition is
fragmented uh and the working class
element has simply been elbowed aside
and having felt not wanted they've gone
off and voted for somebody else so so
the key task for labor and i think this
is something that as i said before
neither the liberal left or the radical
left within the party get is you have to
start speaking the language and
reflecting the priorities of those
people you have to make a pitch to the
jillian duffy's of this world the people
who voted labour once upon a time but
were treated in the end as some sort of
embarrassing elderly relative by the
party and if anyone thinks that you know
just by talking about the armed forces
or laura and order of patriotism those
voters are going to come flocking back
they're going to have a rude awakening
because it has to be rooted i think in
an ideological change an internal
revolution within the party it has to be
rooted in hard policy and you have to
show through that policy development and
through language that you do understand
those voters that you are prepared to
win them back you want to win their
hearts and minds and the you know the
reality is unless you do that you're
never going to win power again
aisha last word to you by the next
election what does your gut tell you
will labor have uh continued to stay in
its comforted little bubble or will it
have branched out in the ways that paul
talks about well i mean again we haven't
talked about scotland in all of this and
you know it does actually show you that
you know
there is a place north of the the red
wall there is this place called scotland
which is really really important because
it's still part of the united kingdom
for the time being and labor is not
going to get to downing street until it
shifts more votes in scotland and
currently there are more liberal and
liberal democrat mps and pandas than
there are uh labour mps in scotland and
labour used to be absolutely dominant in
scotland particularly in the west of
scotland where i grew up where you know
the pillars of society were football
rangers and celtic the church and the
labour party and the trade union
movement so i
let the red wall is very very important
but it is not the only thing that labor
has to think about and just think about
the values that people have in scotland
as well because there is a lot of it's
very fashionable to be like oh the
labour party just you never thinks about
the north which there is i have a lot of
sympathy for but it literally doesn't
think about scotland either and kirsten
has got to shift the needle in scotland
otherwise
it's just not going to happen
in terms of where i think labour will be
as we run up to the next general
election
i do think this week is very important
in terms of this was the turning point
where the labour party stopped just
being a complete joke and a rabble and
it began to be a serious contender with
its eyes on power instead of just
virtuous opposition
and but there is a long long way to go
kyostarma has to get a bigger swing than
tony blair did in 1997 to just to get a
sort of majority of of one so it is
going to be really difficult
but i think he is very serious about
this really interesting looking at the
coverage today actually quite a lot of
the right wing papers are saying that
you know he he did it he did a good job
and i think that's that's that's a big
moment you know to sort of be looked at
as a credible you know prime minister in
in waiting i thought the picture in the
front of the telegraph today was was
you know money couldn't buy that picture
kia starmer with his wife looking like a
sort of normal um person sometimes those
kind of you know partners coming up at
the end of conference could be really
really cringe for for sort of a labor
leader who looked really sort of awkward
about the whole thing he does have a
confidence about him listening to him
today on the radio as well just talking
about his time as director of public
prosecution he is a serious man
and we are entering very very serious
times you know people not being able to
fill their cars up real worry about fuel
bills on the horizon food shortages like
a lot of chaos on on the horizon so
while he has got a long way to go and i
would never underestimate the
campaigning juggernaut that is boris
johnson
you know if things continue to be very
very tricky and competence and planning
does get cut through with the public
then i think kyo starmer
could be much more of a contender than
people have ever thought him capable of
aiushin paul thanks for joining
spectator tv
[Music]
you